hey how's it going I'm Jake I'm here
with John Luke and we're about to play
awesome lawbreakers yeah don't break the
law
all right let's yeah this is the beta
which started yesterday for those who
have early access to it it will be a
open starting tomorrow and then it goes
until the 3rd which I believe is Monday
yes you and I both had a chance to play
quite a bit yes so we played a couple
rounds late a couple rounds did really
well which means I'll probably do
terrible today yeah everyone keeps in
the chat saying this is overwatch oh boy
all right just getting right into it huh
so I mean I to be fair like considering
a lot of maybe not hate but people are
pretty lukewarm about this maybe we
should talk about what we sure you think
about it because initially when I saw
this game and when I I did a live stream
with mic a couple months ago I was
thinking that this is like I wasn't too
interested it seemed very generic Robb
but I actually got my hands on it
recently and it's actually pretty fun it
does clearly lack character which
overwatch has yeah or like a character
that you like I mean it's got character
but it's very robe a key
edge to it yeah start with so they have
eight classes now there's a secret ninth
class that's unlocked
yeah there's no sniper in this game so
that makes sense I've tried them all
actually like all the mix-up for the
battle medic but only because they have
a grenade launcher I don't particularly
care for right now I'm just gonna start
with Vanguard and if anyone has any
requests we can certainly get into that
later the thing I understand why people
compare games to overwatch it's the
popular game this easiest thing to
compare to it's got classes with
characters in it but I'd say the big
difference is overwatch is very team
composition where every classes aren't
meant to be balanced against each other
right it's more much more like chess
right like a mercy isn't necessarily
meant to kill a road hog in a one-on-one
right yeah in this game every class can
easily stand their own against every
other class yeah so that's not really
it's more about which class you prefer
and which kind of fits your playstyle
the best and I think there's a little
more totally I'll try my best to to play
and talk see I do I'll do I also really
like the modes in this game alive I
think they're all like pretty creative
and inventive twist on formulas
especially overcharge which is the Babri
one hopefully we'll get that turn the
sound down I really like the Jake turn
your mics I I really like the sort of
take on domination how basically right
when you capture point it's locked in
and you get that point all right and
then it resets and you have to capture
again I think it's it's kind of cool you
don't see that as often boy yeah we were
doing pretty good you know yeah I'm not
doing I'm not doing so hot right now
these games go I feel or you know it's
like you know when I was playing
yesterday not that maybe people probably
in as much so it's like I got all the
noobs in it and now I feel like that's
how it typically goes with me when it
comes to first-person shooters all is
that I'm feel like I'm generally pretty
decent first-person shooters right so
when I start you didn't already well but
as the system I keep on bigger off the
casuals start to start to lose interest
and then that's when I don't do as well
okay and game looks exactly like
overwatch all past look exactly like it
really is it like I said like it plays
very differently like the structure and
the objectives in how you operate and
what you're doing
is very different yeah um an open
monitoring chat the whole time so if you
guys have any questions feel free to ask
them like when is the ps4 beta I don't
know then is it the same time you know I
think it's a little later they have it
on their website they have it listed
there is going to be a ps4 yeah there'll
be a ps4 beta we're playing right now in
PC I saw someone say it's just the game
where you shoot behind yes line fire
mode you know every character can do
that I did not know that so that may
sound weird in terms of like oh well why
would I ever do like the chance did you
actually killing somebody
by shooting behind you seems kind of so
slim that you wouldn't wouldn't bother
but it has a secondary use and that is
when you are in the zero gravity areas
you shoot behind you it propels you
forward you get yourself moving faster
that's pretty cool in zero-g which is
actually really really useful in certain
situations um I'm gonna ask for class
using this is the van gogh's the
Vanguard which has this chain gun and
you can kind of like fly around the map
you know okay
overwatch kind of a diva in that sense
although they're not like a tank
necessarily like diva then they got this
uh
kind of grenade you throw and then you
have this charge ability where you kind
of can ground slam into somebody how
many game modes look I've just done quit
playing there's turf war there's
overcharge there's little link and
there's blitz ball so back at that's
before I can think of blitz ball is
really fun to I like less balls fun the
ball is voiced by Justin roiland which
is pretty good
all right we're out here oh yeah if you
guys have any questions feel free to
drop in the chat if you don't like to
try a different care if you want if you
want me to switch characters any point
um totally cool that alright someone's
coming too late you can skip there's no
one oh this is the the turf war this is
what I was talking about the thing on
conquest I like it oh wow we got me um
oh wreath that's the class you like a
lot he's got this like a little
submachine gun and then a knife yeah the
rape is a lot of fun I really like knife
thing and this is very satisfying like
when you public sword finisher or
something like that right and they like
basically explode because you know a
knife someone they usually explode
switch up here is this better than big
rigs over the road racing uh no no no
thickens no perfectly a GameSpot gave
the game a perfect ten yeah as it
deserves do you think this game will
last
that's a good question yeah that's a
very good question in terms of uh
they're they're really pushing the
eSport aspect of this game yes but at
the same time they're not pushing it in
a way that I find off-putting like an
issue I've always had with I've always
hated like games where they're very much
trying to be like eSports see before it
finds a community this game seems more
like they're leaving it open for eSports
and if the community kind of really
comes around it and that works out well
when I went to pax and an e3 I don't
know if you saw their booth at e3 but I
had like an announcer and they were like
oh to be fair that makes sense in a it
does environment like that I'm more
talking about when they put out like
those promotional videos where it's like
a fake eSports commentary
yeah okay but I cringe at I think it all
said this game's gonna be only thirty
dollars and I think it's a very
appropriate price for this game
as a 30 or 40 I know it's 30 ok 30 bucks
30 bucks
no microtransactions I believe I think I
thought there were but they were tossing
yeah there are loop boxes in this game
which if I get some later with me we can
open up there okay I know I open I'm
like yeah I think they like that is
don't care they certainly like the flash
of a overwatch Audrey - that for sure I
think that's my god I'm not doing good
today someone says you suck at this game
yeah you're wrong at least today when is
the console beta someone in the chat
said become the console beta has not
been announced yet
oh I thought they were I thought there
was I thought they said there was they
were doing one though maybe they I think
there's doing one maybe just needs to
date because I've three yeah it sounded
like they were gonna do it all so I need
like I'm not really focusing on the
objectives someone asked I was locks
yeah someone says they're not pushing
the eSport aspect of this game at all
cliffy B even said it's explicitly that
he didn't care for it and if it's
happened and if it happened that's that
yeah that's that's what he said during
our yeah interview um wait right I mean
that night I still yeah I still think
that I could yeah when I've seen this
I've seen this game a couple times at
events like it packs and stuff like that
and they it definitely seems like they
want to they definitely wouldn't
complain if this ended up being sure oh
sure sure and to be fair it's a it's
hard because events like that like
that's the best way to show off a game
like this oh yeah they had professional
commentators like commentating these
games they were like pulling the best
players and trying to have tournaments
and stuff like that
and
yeah my father all the characters in
this game I nice basically swim like
different versions of clip Phoebe's
personality be like you get it killing
like I deserve that or like the eight
the eight sides of cookie yeah
someone says titanfall so I saw this to
be honest reminds me more of titanfall
than it does sure very different it
focus on mobility but in a different way
yeah in terms of like yard stop - I yeah
definitely
lost bad isn't games them quick soon
yeah I think it is I am that be fun
use enjoy that I forget that they do it
multiple times a year yeah one year we
actually did a whole games done quick
livestream here there's some of that
what that was telling the chat says rip
rip yeah hopefully we're getting a
better better match here I'll see the
match like a different if this is a
ranking system where they rank your
match see that's appropriate probably
maybe even addy it's a competitive arena
shooter eSports gets thrown around heaps
with titles like these but I just
remember him being particularly
ambivalent regarding it yeah that's
probably fair and eSports does get
thrown around a lot I can't argue with
that but just from my perspective being
there I was like like alright they
definitely want to make this this
something brings up a some brought up
arena shooter interesting point I do
think this game actually feels different
from quick champions which is the other
like arena shooter they are both arena
shooters but in terms of like where this
game could fit I think both those games
could equally like fit in this space
without encroaching on each other at
least in terms of the way they play
someone says wow that was a bunch of men
used to sit through before entering
another game yeah that is one thing I've
noticed is when you complete a game it's
like next next right well I next you did
leave I did leave because I wanted to
get different group of people
so the assassin I I like to find the
assassin in the
early early alpha where there's only
four characters I've doing a lot worse
with them now because I feel like they
changed him a little bit I can show them
off though
I love the momentum of them but they are
definitely overpowered we were getting
our asses handed to me last night when I
was playing with some friends by
assassins but I love the speed of the
graphics yeah it's pretty cool Billy
says gdq is this weekend thanks for
stopping by and thank you for letting
people know that stuff's always really
right I guess this is uplink which
essentially yeah you got this satellite
that you grab and you bring over to your
base and then it charges at your base
and the charge is it's similar to
overcharge which is the battery one the
difference between the two is overcharge
the battery itself charges with uplink
your base is the one charging up so if
we were to steal it and bring it back
they would keep their percentage we have
to start at zero and get it up with
overcharge the battery itself is just
charging so what I like about that mode
is they could get the battery charged to
100% and then you could steal the
battery and instantly score like just
let them do all the work and then just
oh man Bob Jones says Heil
how's it going how are you doing
gentlemen I'm doing okay I'm not at the
game but uh I'm just overall I'm fine
yeah well I've some some actual good
gameplay going up on YouTube later right
I did way better yeah I I like the 0g
area - I thought it would become EPF
first no hi it's Jake from State Farm
that is me Jake from State Farm although
I'm not wearing khakis let's go to
gunslinger get this cool warp you get
this nice that you throw that um way
tells me where enemies are okay looks
like it was right on Oh got me Vanguard
other meteor
so we need to our team is not Bethany
once again says lawbreakers no overwatch
or very different games lawbreakers
seems more far more mechanic heavy as
opposed to over watches game sensibility
management aspects yeah I think I think
when people actually play this game or
if people actually play this game they
will realize that like wall comparisons
to overwatch completely valid it is dang
that's the thing about that assassin
they get up on you and you're your daddy
it's not much you can do about it come
on guys
racks playstation says you guys are you
guys are doing a terrible job and have
little to no knowledge of the game you
play like a bleeped out a monkey would
do better if he has a hat cool I kind of
lost you at the end there about the
hacks but I mean a monkey there's the
Hat make them better better if so can
you can we get that hat yeah I'll wear
that hat
he says agree to disagree okay I'm lost
all right
hey Joey looks like jean-luc on
Thursdays oh I didn't Joe he's supposed
to normally do with you ya mean Friday
usually do a Fridays okay we're not
doing a Friday stream though because a
little game called Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild has some DLC got DLC
coming out tomorrow tonight actually Oh
Callie
Kelly's cleared this up for us the
monkey from Futurama had a hat that made
him smarter I remember this oh okay it's
a feature Rama joke okay I've been I
respect that because he trauma is
fantastic yeah your joke was not though
team where's my team red Diggity Dog
since I like a hat who doesn't like a
good hat yeah the race going here hey
this guy's even slide and you can wall
jump whoo good mobility to this guy
although I'm really bad with his um he
can throw his knife and then it will
eventually explode he found so shoot it
I find that really hard to lose
effectively Dick's AVD says I song done
any of the storing breath of the wild
guess the aim of doing it before DLC is
dead well the DLC at least this one is
not story related so I feel like it it's
slots in a way where you can just kind
of just gotta become part of the game
yeah I would recommend you in this story
though oh yeah absolutely
the second DLC that looks very story
heavy so you might want to take heard
the story before you get to that one
someone brought up player unknown
battlegrounds that game is really cool
I haven't played yet still I wanted I
want I know hoping it would be on sale
house hoping it would be on sale I think
that game is doing too well to be on
right now and like from prop a good
points in early access and you know it's
like okay I guess but no no whatever man
like it's doing so well I don't need the
extra money it's right there to shop
that and then I could explode it by
shooting at it but just like actually
getting somebody in that fire it was
like for me time yeah I know the nice
move are the shooting a knife I don't I
think it's cool but like you know times
I actually hit someone with it is never
there we go
alright oh that I hit dude I got that
guy right there that was cool oh that's
not doing bad there I was okay yeah
all right our team I might I don't know
what my team is doing though they're not
running the objective I've noticed that
in this game yeah well don't like to run
the objectives maybe because it's still
new in these objectives or yeah and you
just got like no throw my friend a
little bit under the bus here where you
spent he's like guys I have 17 kills I
was like cool uh how's the objective
going he's like haven't bothered with
that like thanks oh nice I noticed some
maps have green lines on the ground that
will point you to the health station
yeah that's really cool that's really
key I feel like it's learning where the
health stations are in this so we lost
bad what's with all this sliding on the
floor bollocks and knew it FPS is who
does that well I guess I guess that is
it appeared a lot I don't know I like it
it's kind of nice too so yeah in real
life I don't think that'd be very
effective if you slid towards someone
you just get shot they just slightly
look down this whole game devoted to
that called vanquish it's pretty good
it's true so yeah and that's also only
Justin's character there's no like
crouched in this game yeah I did notice
that I was trying to do that but I kind
of like cuz I think about most fast
paced games like this and like I don't
need it crouched like that's not a thing
I need this game yeah why would I ever
crouch can you you can crouch in
titanfall right you can't crouch in
titanfall yeah but yeah I don't think I
ever I can't think of many situations
where like oh thank God I can crouch
right now cuz it's gotta move
no stash drops yet got a level up yeah
gotta play better hopefully we get into
games because that was one issue we were
having yes and we're playing together
have that later later at night I think
it's because we had we were grouped up
I've noticed games sometimes have a
little bit tougher time finding matches
and keeping you in matches when you're
grouped under your group especially even
that's something that's an issue with
overwatch I feel like they still haven't
really worked out like if you're in a
group of four or five it can be really
enough to get a game there's a scam
there's a couple of cool things
well for one actually like grouping up
is pretty quick like you just had a
button and you're like some games like I
feel like it takes forever just to like
get a party with people
this game doesn't pretty quick which is
nice this game has built in discord
support which is me oh yes I remember
hearing about that basically if you
aren't already in a discord the game
will put you in like in your friends in
a temporary discord channel that's
pretty cool which is pretty neat be cool
for more games start to do things like
yeah and then the other one is I had the
game crash on me
I know cool right and it's a beta cool
really rad feature but when I loaded the
application back up it actually put me
right back in the match
I was already in just okay immediately
well they gave me the option of like oh
do you want to go back a match or not
but that's like I don't not many games
to do that that's pretty cool oh boy so
let's cancel try again yeah sometimes um
I've had I get in pretty quick and a
match other times it takes a while yeah
like that was pretty quick yeah exactly
um so a little weird you know it's a
beta they're still working out the kinks
the game comes out in two months still
you know sure I did say VD says imagine
if Nintendo games with discord support
instead of their weird squid peripheral
yeah I mean at a certain point it's like
there's a phone app for discord might as
well just seems that right yeah it's a
bit weird
so I didn't think I'd like this guy at
first cuz he's um just got this shotgun
very heavy very slow but um for
defending this guy is really really good
he throws up a shield right yeah he
throws up the shield like that and then
um also has this armor he'll put on we
were damn I took like a couple rockets
to the face it John Luke and I were
playing yesterday we played Oh boots
ball and someone on the other team was
playing this character and whenever we'd
almost get to the ball baby show which
is really smart pretty cool he was also
the only one on Steam actually doing
anything and his name was also
lawbreakers so I wonder if he was like
on the development team annuity was
doing right cliffy be himself Lang yeah
alright so this is over charge we grab
the battery we can get this here oh yeah
you're just like oh so he's got this um
just charged run where he'll just like
knock people over if he hits them which
I didn't I just died but if you're in
the air and you do what you do like a
ground town
enemy is charging the battery
yeah you do
like the max yeah that's played homemade
Maps
yeah that looks satisfying ah-huh as
expected
what do you have no are you a robot
mm-hmm this one I'm a robot but I feel
like when he dies he still explodes in
blood sometimes I feel like I've seen
that happen all right keep it on well
like I've knifed one in it like exploded
in blood like mm okay
and it makes like the like mushy
explosive variety everything feels good
like the weapons feel good to use are
you got yeah what like the weapons feel
good to use like there's good like sound
effects you know it's very well made
game all right quake more than overwatch
is certainly in that it's arena shooter
like I wouldn't call overwatch an arena
shooter it's a it's a class-based you
know it's more TSU
armored fight there's no beta for ps4
yeah nope not yet
this is gonna be open beta though
starting tomorrow
especially once again he says the only
issue I have with this game is the maps
look rather bland with identical color
palette honestly need some more variety
i I agree with that I think the maps
like I said before I think the maps are
well designed but right maybe not super
interesting there's a couple that are
good stand there's a couple that have
like this one's pretty bland visually
all agree it's just like like base that
right that yeah white walls with blue or
red
yeah like lab base thing with weapons
and yeah I agree but there is one I
forget what it's called but it more of
that that one's kind of because any
anything that has a Japanese seems to
Palmer
right yeah because it is it's on a cliff
and I mean you still see areas like this
which is kind of annoying but yeah cool
let's get a tropical island map with
lots of colors yeah that'd be pretty
cool I noticed that uh Call of Duty
infinite warfare has a map like that
that I think just came out right maybe
then just kinda haven't played enough
warfare much at all but I didn't I was
like the player I know I didn't care
much for either but I saw that as I read
I kind of want to play I always loved it
when Call of Duty when they made those
maps that like didn't really fit like
they made one in like an amusement park
that was really cool I think for black
ops 2 mm-hmm but yeah I think of a Blade
Runner like neon Knight map was you
awesome in this yeah I think that would
fit
what was the name of that game Vietnam
Xbox announced during their press
conference that almost look like a Blade
Runner sort of styled oh the pixel one
maybe someone in the chat knows
something night
yeah like the characters were pixeled
right but yeah the backgrounds were man
that game looks so cool
yeah visually the game looked amazing
don't have that game actually plays or
what kind of game it is Oh get the help
there was a line back there alright
oh you're right alright follow the line
yeah oh good good call oh it's called
the last night the last night there we
go
how about trees full of radiation yeah
be interesting I like to see some more
maps play with the gravity stuff in the
sense that I mean all of them do but
like less ground and more having to be
in gravity all the time
I don't know if I'd be too hazardous
though like you're you're wearing too
much about the environment yeah about
shooting like there's a delicate balance
I imagine yeah for sure I don't know
what their plans are as far as
they're gonna release three now problem
is I get there and my team's there is
this how do I not look like overwatch
it's not a fake RPG mechanics way
different what I don't know does this
look like a watch I mean watch is a fake
RPG mechanics out sorry dude oh it
floats - that's pretty cool
oh yeah you can put it wherever moon map
were parts of it
anything low gravity very cool isn't the
last light last night the one with
controversy jean-luc yeah the last night
the the creators are apparently some
probe gamergaters okay okay say say some
kind of not so savory things on the
social medias okay I didn't follow it
that much I just saw the trailer and I
was like wow this looks rad right yeah
so I think he's on moon yeah I feel like
I was trying my best and my team was
just not there for me on that one let's
see if I can get it let's try to get one
good match here yeah in this dream I
think we can do it I hope we can do it
all right I'm gonna look up this beta
thing we're gonna enough talk about it
does any character have a turret
likability to stick to walls in the
zero-g areas no nothing where you can
stick turrets on anything lobby
alright let's cancel I think I feel like
it's this faster for me to cancel start
over I got a match quitter
who the blitzball cool blitzball fun
although every match of blitzball i've
done it's been fairly one-sided I know
oh hi there I'd kick butt Orie our just
getting just ride
alright I like playing rape the slides
really that was awful
it looks like this beta is only for PC
ok I think people already knew right but
they're there I know there will be a ps4
beta at some point feel fairly confident
we got a good we got a good question
here so the guys at games stop how are
the servers in matchmaking working
smoothly getting kicked a lot and then
you responded sorry GameSpot that's fine
happens all the time
sometimes I like almost X I'm like
game's spy so I like I said sometimes it
seems like it takes a little bit to get
in to a match not that long though for
the most part it's pretty smooth I've
never been kicked from a match yeah I
have had trouble sometimes getting in
where he like takes forever and we had
to like restart or just it kept cycling
to get us in a match but once I've been
in a match it's been smooth I haven't
noticed yeah we mentioned a little
earlier but I think at least the most
issue I've had with getting to a match
was when we were parted up and trying to
play together
well you know
no lawbreakers is not heading to Xbox
not now
cliff he said he would it says it could
yeah you could eventually but right now
they're just focusing on Julie C on the
platforms and getting it getting it
going in and from then maybe they'll put
on Xbox he says thanks for understanding
and answering my question you're welcome
you got any more we're gonna guy oh that
was close
oh no I think the the race is really
good in this mode I agree
like really good in this mode yeah but
you know even like the like we were
saying the the slow guide the juggernaut
you think you wouldn't be good but then
you can use them as a defensive like
pretty effective yeah some of the chats
the characters remind me a lot of
Paragon I haven't played a lot of
Paragon but I have some friends who are
really into it and I actually I can kind
of see that I can there's that influence
for you know cookie sort for epic and
paradigms made by epic this runs on
Unreal Engine so there's definitely some
certain art aesthetic that I imagine
carries over that lineage Bob Jones says
I just hope there will be a traditional
FPS on the switch one day and score nice
I kind of hope so too
I I'm really excited for splatoon though
splatoon to I know that's not a again
what game would you want on the the
switch well what type of shooter like
was being a jerk this was like he was a
kid you hear a wolfenstein scum to
switch and I got really excited me too
and he's like no I just said that and
I'm like great I think laughing Stein
would be cool on switch for me I'm
probably just saying that cuz I mean I'm
excited for splatoon I'm super excited
for splatoon
I'm more excited for Super Smash Bros on
switch which hasn't been announced yet
and if they don't announce I'm gonna cry
sweats and he says sorry if I had
keeping the staff pronouncing your name
this god I love Paragon did you ever
play John did you ever play Paragon now
I'm not really no MOBAs but I have some
friends who play Paragon yeah and are
really into it it seems like a very good
game yeah I have some friends who were
so into it so I'm kind of tempted to try
it but all right Ron dude there's
stories of mr. and mrs. J says GameSpot
do you think this going to survive on
the ps4 because of how fast paced the
game is so you played a little bit the
ps4 versions like they slowed it down
enough where it still works for the
control yeah I actually thought it
played pretty well on ps4 definitely
have to play on PC I think that's
definitely what I prefer but playing
with a gamepad was actually it felt
pretty good yeah it's not like it has
cross play or anything where you'd have
mouse keyboard people against controller
people or anything like that so that
would just be very off-putting
yeah you can't play this game with a
controller on PC I don't think you
should though you will you will not have
a good time
Oh once again specs in yet Stephanie and
I sorry if I continue to miss bradster
name we're best friends because he just
said I'm excited for buying for Witcher
3 again on PCs CD Projekt RED can have
all of my dollar II dues I've played The
Witcher 3 four times that is what about
The Witcher on switch which one switch
the switcher this is already another
swap right let's swap the switcher oh
man switcher edition would be so cool
boy I'd play that
AJ Taurus is Jake I'm with you lol as
soon as they announce Super Smash Bros
force which I'm going to drop some
dollars on this switch you yeah I mean
good system like I have the switch now
and I love Zelda's all this fantastic I
love Mario Kart 8 so you want to play
that again
but honestly Smash Bros is the only
reason I ever get a no not the only
reason but it's one of the key reasons
why I get Nintendo consoles and even if
they rerelease super smash bros wiiu on
switch which i hope they do because that
means we'll get it sooner I will get
some points okay on this one I really
want to switch it now switcher
let me I wonder how that visually look
that I don't think I don't think they
could do it that'd be a little tough it
would be downgraded but honest I mean
like mechanically that'd be really fun
yeah
what about you go there any first-person
shooters on the switch yeah that
satisfying I mean I think it would be
cool since they've already done a
remaster of Call of Duty 4 I think that
would be a cool way - that would be a
solid shooter to put on the switch and I
think it would be a good way for the for
Call of Duty the the team to test
whether or not these games can do well
on a Nintendo console game because I
know they stopped making an entire right
after a while for titanfall be cool
folks like titanfall now playing with
the pro controller would be pretty good
that's a good controller yeah
you got it definitely have to do some
downgrading to get titanfall on that I'm
sure though visually sure but but yeah I
can get yeah it's running at like a
smooth 60 yeah oh okay
they made a really good port of
titanfall one on our blue point I think
was it it made a really good titanfall
one for on Xbox 360 Peter Brown was
saying that was actually his preferred
way to play but I think it was cuz he
didn't ever call it on PC which I
enjoyed some brings a good point uh much
of kron4 is gonna be an FPS although
it's a more like a first-person in
adventure game with yeah shooting it's
not a different beast like a
first-person like Metroidvania game
yeah but yes that will theoretically
have I'm curious what the controls for
that will be because like are they gonna
you know three had the motion control
yes and they then they we made them with
wine to motion controls which are
actually pretty good
yeah I heard motion controls for that
we're actually somewhat these Malick
played one and two I have another the
plane I I liked those quite a bit that
trilogy collection is really really good
but I wonder if they'll go back to the
GameCube style controls although that
Dave Bing controls were also different
cuz I'd only had one analog stick so I'm
very curious how they're gonna make that
gameplay yeah I'm excited for that game
me too never I've never thought I'd see
the day
yeah right man antennae killed it at e3
I thought yeah and they didn't even that
like everyone thought for sure it was
gonna be Smash Bros alright and even
without that without it I was still
impressed right my heart still would
have been more impressed I would have
yeah I've lost my Shi T that's one of
those things where I always uh
lid off the ball slid off the edge I
always feel like maybe we should have
some sort of like camera recording us in
the war room and things gonna now like
went like an announcement like for like
a reaction thing were you there during
Sony's press conference where they
announced Final Fantasy 7 remake Shenmue
3
here now that was I imagine that was
people were freaking out and I also
showed off what Kingdom Hearts 3 I think
for that before like oh that was the as
Lucy refers to at the e3 of dreams the
e3 of dreams can we just get crazy taxi
on switch the kind of cool heavy cool I
just wanna have anything on switch me to
it's just that's a platform I'm just a
man it's just so nice like maybe not
hardcore RPGs but even then I still kind
of do what I mean Zelda you know that's
true well that's that's why I'm like
Witcher I'm like that I think a witch on
the switch that sounds great yeah and
I'd refer to it as the special switcher
which is the main reason why I want the
witch run switch I think rocket League
on switch is gonna be rad - yeah
especially because it's gonna be cross
play between PC not on ps4 though which
is our primary primary method of playing
on yeah the office but exactly do we
might all switch over to the switch I
think Rob is I mean I probably would
yeah we're robbing Peter go is where
everyone else pretty much is yeah the
ones who are still playing it we all
just kind of join them occasionally
Dick's AVD says apparently there were
people inside he through Sony press
conference with professional lights and
cameras pointed at them for reaction
stop some journalists said it was ending
I cannot do that and I enough I knew the
lineup for Sony's press conference at a
time I would have done the same thing
like this is we need reactions for this
for sure
so this fable would be better than
switcher
I mean fable would be cool but actually
yeah I think fable would be really cool
and that would happen don't think it
would someone asked back to LA break oh
yeah you got beta so it actually opens
up tomorrow so anyone can join the beta
on PC starting tomorrow and it goes
until Monday and especially says not
saying favor was better than the wit
shirt just switcher sure yeah I mean I
think I think fable would definitely fit
that more because it's not as maybe
mechanic having me that's not the right
word is the Witcher there's a lot to
keep track of in The Witcher as opposed
to fable right but with updated lowering
graphics yeah but yeah I don't think
that will happen I think Microsoft would
I think if it's not called Microsoft or
if it's not called minecraft Microsoft's
not gonna put it on anything else you
know what I actually love to see I would
love to see a reimagining of The Witcher
1 did I love that game
I love the lore in the story I think
mechanically it's real rough I'm slowly
playing through it and it's tough to
stop like it's got a lot of good stuff
in it that I think makes it worth
playing but it's a hard one I recommend
for people yeah and I would like to see
they're originally going to do a console
eyes version of it I remember a rise of
the white wolf and then they ended up
canceling it and just focusing on
because because it was not gonna be
developed by CD Projekt RED it let's buy
like a third-party studio and that end
up getting cancelled and then CD Projekt
RED said we're just gonna do the PC port
of to ourselves and in fact like to is
very much a console eyes game consoles
first
what your wonders not someone says
what's the name of this game I like that
question I know the answer to it is
called lawbreakers ha breakers well the
beta also be available for ps4 at some
point yes but not this open beta it
seems like it seems like this is PC
while said yeah I mean can't you just
imagine cliffy B saying that nope
dang sometimes picking up the objective
with the crown just like a real pain
Richard Westbrook says this guy is so
bad he's so slow doesn't even know his
right-click makes him do a mini - yep
yes I think you're doing fine gentlemen
yeah also wouldn't just out of nowhere
now slide are we yeah we are winning
yeah we're winning we're fine I scored
twice I've contributed yeah it's not
about how many kills you get it's how
many balls you put in the hole what my
dad always told me
then you are flying all over the map
come on chat is broken doesn't load
oh it's loading for us refresh which is
a good tip I don't really realize think
about that how this does like yeah
actually the melee is like heaven far
range with this guy like you'll - quite
a bit and even if it doesn't look like
you hit him like you still yeah the
boots kind the same ball oh I have the
ball I didn't realize that oh man I I
feel like sometimes it can be clear when
you have the ball I yeah I've done that
before
like I only knew because it said right
there and that little tiny thing and
it's like I don't know that joke or
characters absolutely one says I would
love to see a war game for Mass Effect
planet or galaxy-wide you mean like a
multiplayer only game that a
first-person shooter because I remember
Mass Effect they were gonna make it were
working on or a first-person shooter
mode multiplayer I was gonna be a
standalone game
Oh panel oh yeah it didn't make it it's
gonna be like it had like vehicles it
was basically gonna be like a
battlefield
planetside 2 yeah or something like that
American cheese says can you give me a
shout out there homie I'm single please
what kind of American cheese cabott
question Luke because shout outs are
entirely dependent on what kind of yeah
you gotta tell us what kind of cheese
are
call of lawbreakers I switch a class up
skit uh easy target says I'm too old and
fat for this twitch hyperactive caffeine
mainlining ADHD game LMAO ferret fair
enough I might be too
I was playing yesterday like guys like
it can be a lock it is scored come on
guys we just gotta get the one more
Tommy yo Patrice's can I give a code
away I don't know
Oh like if you want to give one to a
friend um if you have a code I think it
means like give one drop one in the chat
if you want a man uh yeah if you don't
write it like where you guys fair one
you want to give it to somebody go for
it man
all right who's got the ball you can
wall jump as well this yeah oh no not
just now the other one yeah
come on get him oh god oh that was close
guys dang
jawbreakers I thought about that earlier
I couldn't think of like a good joke yes
this is the enforcer Johnny Z says who
watches estream so boring you do dude
pretty cool
well you should definitely watch Peter
and Rob's Zelda screen Peter rob anytime
they stream anything much funnier than I
think best pair streams if they win this
game I'm going to tweet a hand-drawn
picture of cliffy B to Kanye West what's
your Twitter handle yeah I want that I
want to visit John Luke there's a lot at
stake here now there is a lot at stake
so I asked if Justin roiland is the ball
yes
yeah American she says I'm gonna
subscribe thank you so much thank you so
much American cheese all the subscribes
help and if you are enjoying this we do
stream
well someone says it's not interesting
but if you are enjoying this we do
stream every day at 11:00 Monday through
Friday yeah and those games range for
everything Monday Mike and i streamed
Wolfenstein because we're very excited
for Wolfenstein a new Colossus tomorrow
it's gonna be the new Zelda P although
we will not have streams Monday and
Tuesday because we are not in the office
that is a good point we won't have
streams man there consolidate
Wednesday though will be the lobby and
then no it's Thursday but I mean Jo we
have a fun stream plan for Friday hey we
won won we won all right what's your
Twitter hand where is it I want it this
this needs to happen make sure to
include John Luke and I just press ctrl
I assume they're saying for the blind
fire actually remapped it to the middle
mouse button cuz it's not being used for
anything so
that's what you're saying oh these these
aren't this these are not what I wanted
or these aren't the bindings you yeah
play with and then hey jean-luc you got
it you got a s.o.b on this last good
point SS it may be platinum probably not
SS for Japanese do you though they like
s and then like SS Triple S oh you're
right sometimes do ooh let's get a super
time the stache drop and I just realized
it has a mustache cuz it's okay I just
got that
and wasn't really paying attention that
earlier I'm really cute I want to see
this hand-drawn picture of cliffy B
that's being tweeted too funny anyone
says all money alright its first time
some skins oh gosh then you got to boss
ones
alright gunslinger skins that's cool
both you got to look at you got there
higher than exotic oh wow
also of course we got three actually
because that one is credit drops wow I
was actually really good drop dang cool
now that's different from overwatch
because only you get a bunch of skins or
this or you get a bunch of I don't want
to spray paints and then the same skin
you've gotten 12 times I'm not bitter
about it or anything though uh what do
you think one more game yeah keep it
home for a bit cool
son asks any Opie characters um if
you're really good with the assassin oh
boy they're gonna be rough when you got
a really good assassin just like getting
all all up in your space otherwise I
feel like they're pretty balanced if
anything I like the gunslinger I feel
like they're a little underpowered I
agree I think the gunslinger could use a
little bit of a boost and I just I like
the Battle of mages abilities I just
don't like their weapons
you got like a grenade launcher as your
standard which just isn't really my
thing and then their alternative pistol
I think it's just not like I rather use
an another character yeah I think from
what I've played at least so far I
haven't really noticed anyone that seems
overpowered however there are definitely
characters that people tend to prefer
over others right for example wraith
people really like the race part of the
problem because I really like The Rave
yeah I'll try the Titan a little bit the
Titans okay I like it more than I
thought I would yeah I really used the
Titan well you can just rocket jump as
that hey rocket jump you got this ground
slam this move like like ups the gravity
and it like sends them down and so then
you can just like shoot them banana man
says what is your guys who spend the
game favorite game that's tough ooh
like ever oh geez oh boy I don't know
that's a tough one I mean I can rattle
off a few I don't know if I can favorite
among those Majora's Mask yeah them a
link to the a Link to the Past actually
think I like a Link to the Past more the
majora's mask but i classify 3d and 2d
gel bit differently Tales of Symphonia
Splinter Cell chaos theory The Witcher 3
of course The Last of Us pokémon red and
blue
so there those are just a few sure I put
them on gold and silver for me oh yeah
like I'm blue I think I do like gold and
silver better but the the the amount of
time and nostalgia I had the amount of
time I spent with red and blue and the
amount of nostalgia I have for those
games is probably beyond red and blue I
mean gold silver okay yeah
American cheese says Skyrim is his fave
scams a good pic I think my thing was
kinda was that I played a heck of a lot
of oblivion yeah I I definitely more of
a fun I hit a mid-air I did I have more
of a fondness for oblivion and I think
the more wins the the best of yeah so by
the time I finally played moral when I
had already put in like 200 hours and so
that's like skyrim is a great game but
like oblivion for nostalgia and then as
far as quality I'd say persona for one
of my favorite games oh that's a good
price
absolutely adore that game like Halo 3
and Halo 3 is a good choice I think I
like I think I like Halo 2 more butter
I've played halo 3 ball more and I
probably had way more fun with Halo yeah
I like I'll just never forget like hit
what you multiplayer I think it's the
better of the multi wars but I think
halo 3 is an overall package but I still
remember like going to gamestop non-game
spot at midnight and getting Halo 2
there getting the collector's edition
which was only $5 more Wow
was instead of $50 $55 you could upgrade
to the tin collector's edition that came
with behind the scenes
Gaston says maybe we should tell them
the hit f1 so they can see the abilities
I'm aware of what they are I know you
know we know
left 4 dead 1 and 2 is it good choices -
although I would just I would just count
left 4 dead is one especially because -
right you can put up to play all the
originals
Oh Resident Evil remake my name is okay
and I think it's like a flawless game
and and that is a weird case where it's
not a nostalgia because I did not play
it when it came out I did not play
remake until the re-release on like PC
like 2 years ago so it was very much
like not nostalgia I just fell in love
with that game and then resume before
residue Awards up 50 yeah a lot of
Resident Evil I played what about you
guys in the chat with Samir favor grim
someone said hey you Pikachu as a kid
was one of his favorite games
interesting I never I never played I had
fun with that game when I was a little
sure I imagine if I played it now and I
imagine if you played it now - once you
get past in the style - part kind of be
like alright name is black - great
Pikachu does not listen to what I'm
saying
I think Hey You Pikachu would be
bringing that back it's like a phone
concept would be kind of cool yeah
there's an app you know for like
remember Nintendogs Nintendogs right
yeah that was kind of like the evolution
of Hey You Pikachu
I'm dead this guy let's go with I can
show off the battle medic if you want to
see it I'm just might as well it's not
good with it like I feel like healing
team members isn't nearly as important
in this as it is in it's definitely
useful it's useful but like oh no I when
I'm low on health I just went back to
one of those helper stations so I got
this low gravity which is kind of
hovering this time yeah it's just I feel
like I'm taking a lot of hot shots with
this in a way that I'm not super into I
rather dumb-looking pistol
someone said quake overwatch and
lawbreakers are similar I mainly guess
and now they're already they're all
pretty different Hey You Pikachu reminds
me of the detective Pikachu game that
never came out in English that's because
they couldn't get Danny because he
wouldn't do it so why bother that's not
true don't quote us on that but I was
actually thinking about that the other
day I was think about that the other day
too
that's funny actually I think about
detective Pikachu is Danny DeVito many
days so it's not all that good you know
that guy Kingdom Hearts that's a good
choice I have a love/hate relationship
between modes I want I want to like it
but then I play it and like parts of it
I really like other person I hate not
enough for me to call my favorite
American she says all right guys awesome
stream until next time thank you for
stopping by anything happen to subscribe
oh that guy I can heal him to protect
him a little bit alright I got I got
cool again go back to the vanguard dude
you guys don't even know what you're
talking about not sure what you're
referring to but most of the time I
don't know what about but it might be he
might be referring to someone in chat no
he's probably friend girl yeah probably
us team fortress question mark this game
no definitely not this game is
definitely not some purpose
Final Fantasy 3 and Chrono Trigger on
SNES Oh both Chrono Trigger oh man you
know it bums me out a lot Peter already
went on a rant about this all I'm aware
is that Chrono Trigger is not gonna be
on gasps it's a bummer I there must be
some sort of like they could they not
get the mic I don't could they not get
the right it's like I'm not entirely
sure how that shook out but that seems
like a huge mistake I mean they got the
rights for Final Fantasy 6 this
conversation is giving me cancer okay
3-2 win and did we steal the uplink
though no they stole they're just like
all up in our space
would you buy Chrono Trigger on switch I
absolutely I can't oh man off everyone
happen I open up the command let's try
and hit tab and I okay we got the uplink
let's just hold this it's pretty
satisfying moving around isn't right now
we don't have it yeah it's fun
go be careful oh you can get shot down
there's there's an argument going on
about what first-person-shooter MOBAs
are and if this game is like that and
then other people are just slowly giving
us their favorite games The Secret of
Mana that means that's pretty cool
choice
and then other people asking us
questions I were I'm gonna try to stay
out of this I think we we've spoken
enough on how we feel about is this like
overwatch or not right we've given our
in stay out of that so I'm gonna try to
like look at other things
hey GameSpot if you could remaster one
game what would it be for a sauna three
persona three all right that game has
several versions and none of them are
the definitive version for reasons I
won't get into but I would love for
there to be an actual remastered version
of that game I think one you actually
brought up earlier I think is really
cool to do one of our you said
reimagining of The Witcher yeah which
ones also I also want like a solid a
solid it's not even a remastered smell
report I just want Splinter Cell on
modern complements look really good
Splinter Cell chaos theory have a good
you definitely to update the troll oh
yeah for sure know that game is not as
dense as Splinter Cell and Splinter Cell
Pandora tomorrow they kind of like
started to figure things out but it's
still pretty dense
John Davis does you say do you know if
this game will get a physical release on
disc I believe they are planning some
sort of limited edition version of this
game yeah but it seems like it will be a
limited thing but I Marilee it will be
big also it's got buried a little bit
mystery J said one of his favorite games
is Suikoden which is a really good voice
I've never played it but I've heard
really moons very good you can get it on
Vita now I think yeah you can get on
Vita I know you can get on Vita cuz I
have it on Vita I don't know if you can
get it on ps4 ps3 and I think so Oh
another one that we are actually getting
a remaster of is Resident Evil 2 yeah
I'm very excited about that
is that 25% Brandon Burkett says okay
we're done talk about oh boy okay cool
thank God sweet there's another game
that I've been thinking of that really
needs a reboot but I can't remember what
it was or not a reboot but a remaster
remaster reimagining also it might like
my ideal version of like a remastering
of persona 3 would be like there's some
five level graphics like I want them to
like yeah go all out with it so it would
be a it would be a pretty heavy
undertaking which is why I don't think
that'll that'll happen I would like that
what I want this is I guess definitely
more on the reimagining side rather than
a remake from remaster is for that
Pokemon switch game vhost to come out I
think that would be really cool if that
if that game took place in Kanto and in
Johto maybe not like tell the same exact
story hopefully not tell the same exact
story but I think it would be so cool a
full 3d version of light a revisit goes
over like tell a new story like don't
need Team Rocket necessarily but maybe
cool that Team Rocket because I still
think those are the two best area well
actually really like I wonder if they
are eventually gonna go down some sort
of hold like going back to older areas
because Sun and Moon more than any other
game I could think of recently Pokemon
game made a lot of references to all the
other games and the others like a ton of
good in a way that makes me think maybe
they're trying to connect them all more
but you know I think everyone's
dream is the giant Pokemon yeah game
where it has every region in it can you
imagine if that was historical and I
think that's asking for way too much but
I agree I think it is asking for way too
much I think
a joto in Kanto like mixed together I
think is totally doable since they've
already done it
Wow what just happened I was trying to
get that guy and I somehow hit him oh no
guys guys Team Rocket Pokemon game I
used to always and red and blue when you
get to the end of nugget bridge and that
guy asked if you want to join Team
Rocket I always hoped that one time you
can hide ogre in it and it would just
change the whole story
never happens see they're definitely
going to die because team here put one
in the mode there was a pin they'd
Pokemon MMO for a little bit I'm pretty
sure Dan Tendo probably Oh like on that
but I played a little bit of it and it
was cool this game is long yeah this
one's been going for a bit we got one
point at least whereabouts we did I
don't know you got 20 seconds score
timer and there's still a chance oh dang
oh man someone says have you played
overwatch you need teammates you're
wrong you're not wrong defeat defeat all
right let's do at least one more one
more game all right
trango to 12:30 sounds good
so we can get a win - on our last one
it'd be nice we got one win so far I
think right now one football again cuz
we won that I won't read that one out
loud but that's pretty cool
I love psyops they should do a new game
I forgot about psyops
I never played it I've heard good things
alright you're gonna invite a friend you
gonna invite me
yeah plans all about you I've seen
you've gotten off topic with it yeah the
chats talking about Pokemon talking
about switch games I think that's okay
though someone just mentioned Ryse son
of Rome for some reason in the chat
favorite game or no maybe that's what he
wants one switch or a remaster a
remaster it could be any of the several
conversations we have brought up maybe
he wants to travel to Rome in the
Pokemon switch game ah and he wants to
catch gladiators
probably not who knows turf war okay
let's do uh Trek gunslinger again so got
that new skin how's that work yeah I
don't see a difference doesn't really
stand out that much haven't been in love
with the skins options so far they're
okay but yeah they'll I feel like that
but I think games like overwatch is
really old
it is it oh no it's not
after the point or whatever yeah turf
war turf war I like this one walk I'm
feeling you this game people are good at
running objectives too because it's like
it's simpler right
William Ramos says what's your favorite
first-person shooter
putting you on the spot go on favorite
game favorite first-person shooter so it
depends if you're referring to
multiplayer or a single player because I
definitely different it's true
multiplayer to throw the one I engaged
in the most halo 2 & 3
I really titanfall 2 it's a good one as
far as modern ones go first for like a
Sukkah player I don't know man there's a
lot it's really hard to say
Liz James says we have faith in you John
Luke close out with a win oh thank you
I heard that oh [ __ ] you're Mike's a
gunslinger confuses me gunslinger
confuses me too so you know you got the
whole rapid fire here and then you got
this longer shot that you can also be
charged up and then you got this knife
that you throw that can do damage and
also it will show like create a pulse
it'll show enemies and you can do this
little warp you can also do like a warp
and to be shot I don't know if that
actually does boost damage but one of
the tips on the menu were saying like
that counts is like a special type of
kill John Tomatis says you guys should
play player unknowns battlegrounds yes
we should I really want to do a stream
of this game I hope we not done a
student that gun I don't know I yeah I
think it's something that like a little
more involved right yeah I feel like
it's something we'd like to do with
consistency and it's and we want to make
sure people who play are good what you
don't want me on cuz I haven't played it
yet well I mean even me for like I
played a lot of this game but I'm not
all that good you know who's really good
gamespot is Dave Jewett in the UK office
right dick did some videos forever they
have trained they can't really can they
stream their they can but I think yeah
I'm not entirely sure but I think it
would be great for if he was able to do
that because he's really good at that
game but if not I would really like to
do one because I know a lot of us
actually been playing it quite a bit
like Nick Michael and I and Mike playing
quite a bit follow three for single
player for me I don't really consider
fallout3 first-person shooter just
because of I think of more than RPG but
I mean I guess that is definitely that
is definitely an option because you
can't play entirely in first-person mode
now I would have to say maybe it's just
cuz I've been talking a lot about Metro
and think a lot about Metro but Metro
last lights really good yeah I got those
redux versions to prayer 754 both which
is a heck of a deal grodd's rods are
says these guys are bad adios see ya
peace it's just tons of fun and squad
yeah it is like even if we do suck we'd
still have people like grodd's are who
would probably complain but I think
people would still be entertained
because yeah so many like hilarious
moments just between the four of us like
yeah like I think even just as we're
figuring out like accidentally like
pulled the pin on a grenade I didn't
realize when you aim a grenade you
automatic okay so I held onto the
grenade trying to aim up the perfect
throw
meanwhile my entire team and I are in
this little shack and I end up killing
us all that was pretty funny I think
that what we need to do is just find a
day where nothing's really happening
which will have some time the next
couple weeks yeah and pick a day get the
full setup going where we can properly
at least a very least I get everyone's
audio and
yeah if not there screams and play all
day long just play for like yeah for at
least a couple hours right you want to
just kind of keep going for a bit and
like yeah if you are playing by yourself
you can always leave if you lose so it's
not like you're gonna be sitting and
waiting and if you play with four people
and if all them are like ready to stream
then at least someone is and then we can
show him to live you show the person
who's alive exactly is it just me or was
anthem too good to be true and I feel
like I know so little about that game
it's hard to talk about it yeah I'm
excited but I also remember right which
I know is a different Bioware team I did
see that they are they have teased that
they're ramping up development for the
next Dragon Age game which I'm actually
pretty so okay as a big Dragon Age fan I
was a little disappointed in position
but not in a like not like gonna in
Andromeda way where it was like oh this
is bad more just like okay there's stuff
I don't like but there's lost if I
really did like about that game like I
think they could absolutely if they
learn their lessons from it the next one
could be like really really good so yeah
I'm still excited I've been stances I
guess people like destiny in warframe
and stuff will like it but it's not a
game for me that's fair oh right yes I'd
say so that's sort of the thing is it's
the part where like how does this game
how does the buyer wareness of this game
coming apart yeah that's my biggest
question like what they showed seemed
neat but it didn't scream fire where to
me yeah I'm really sick of the trailers
where they fake the voice oh it's
getting really old I remember thinking
to myself like wow we haven't seen any
of that yet I'm so glad and then they
did that and I was like wow okay well
I remember I'm sure they've done it
before but I'd the one that comes to
mind is when they first showed off the
division oh yeah
pretty bad yeah that one was like no one
plays like this ever he charged himself
up Battlefield Bad Company 2 was my
first FPS lose James that game is really
good I really like that game my company
- it was one of the best battlefields
yeah I don't think I've played that one
the most because I didn't have working
internet at the time but I played quite
a bit of that most of the battlefield
game I played the most of was
battlefield 3 which I don't think is my
favorite but it's still very good game
that's good yeah yeah I played it on
console 2 which was like ok family not
how you want to play that game you only
do like 24 players in the game instead
of Richard Westerberg agrees he says
holy F what a great game who some B's
thing about Battlefield Bad Company 2 I
gotta tell ya I wonder if the next I
don't know what the next battlefield
game will be that excited
I hope it's go bad company 3 so I think
the depressing part is the dice has gone
record saying like we don't know why
that game white people love that game
like they basically admitted look we
don't know why people think that's the
best one and like that's sad what are
you talking about I definitely think one
battlefield one has made strides in
returning to the greatness that was bad
company 2 but I don't think they like
surpassed it or anything like that
alright I'm gonna try to make it through
this one
Ronen economy says Capcom got wrecked
this year with mom this Capcom got
wrecked this year with Monster Hunter
world got rekt this year but months from
Monster Hunter rule should be sick but
they should have brought dbo over to the
West's devio Dragon's Dogma online video
I don't know a video it
Dead or Alive no no no no DDO Dragon
song mama maybe I'm an OB Mike yes
people are probably gonna say we're an
idiot cuz we don't know that but don't
know the acronyms you know
goldeneyes set the standard it certainly
did goldeneye although I don't really
have much nostalgia for goldeneye new do
I and I did play as a kid I had a friend
who had a 64 went over and played it but
I know yeah yeah it's dragon style
online I'm waiting for dragons on one
line to come to come to the west what is
Capcom waiting for I still I never got
around to playing Dragon's Dogma I heard
excellent things about it that I've
heard cool
all right guys we need to get be here we
need to hold to Medal of Honor result
and perfect dark was too dark darks good
come on John Luke respond you got to win
well they got beat so we need to get see
you know I'm gonna get a I think you can
get I think you can get this I think
this is you got that guy thanks little
okay we gotta get on see guys I think
it's cuz there's fighting going on come
on Oh dudes dudes no no I'm not gonna
make it on time it's over slide oh no
it's not that character I don't know I'd
run for be first yeah well we lost this
one probably get one more in 1220 yeah
we can we can do one more than one do
one more yeah we had 10 minutes let's do
one more
all right got to get that win can mob
record show in the competitive in a
competitive scenario like we'll have
competitive scene it's gonna entirely
depending on the you know how big the
community is and stuff like that for me
I don't really care so much about the
game has a competitive scene I'm more
care if it just has a healthy player
base for me to keep playing
obviously it's cool when a game I was a
competitive scene but that's something
that like I personally will never engage
with yeah as long as there's enough
people playing that I can like have a
good time that's what I care about
yeah same with me and will this game out
shine overwatch no and that has nothing
to do with the quality of this game
I think overwatch is just such a
juggernaut that it will take a while for
a game to outshine overwatch I don't
think a game while I was trying to
overwatch due to security and gameplay
I think it
similar to tf2 I think eventually
overwatch will just become stale from
just being around so long yeah and then
eventually a new game will come along
that's the harsh truth of it all
sorry sorry game devs trying to be the
new overwatch you just gotta wait Ronon
Okami says sorry boys I'm doing some
shop work while I watch the stream yes
it is dragons dog mom Knight just kind
of disappointed with this year's e3 it
felt mad for some of the stuff I saw we
have had better oh yeah yeah I agree I
think III thought this is a pretty good
e3 yet there's definitely been better I
agree with that but I was really stoked
for some of the stuff like this map I
like like Wolfenstein new Colossus Walt
I thought the first game was definitely
flawed I'm very excited this because
I've had the storytelling the first one
was great
Metro Exodus right anthem looked really
cool I mean I thought Sony's briefing
was the most disappointing yeah I agree
I mean maybe yeas yeah it's a yeah it
was worse I think is wasn't
disappointing because I had a little
very low expectations and I think
Nintendo did a good job for theirs and
seeing Beyond Good and Evil almost made
me cry which was cool acceptance and
then you saw the game and then I saw the
game and I'm like I mean and then you
cry and it's like a cool idea then I
cried again this seems like a cool idea
but it's not exactly what I want when I
want to be on good news again but that's
a whole nother thing for a whole nother
time do you know who voices the
blitzball yes Justin roiland Justin
roiland
spider-man looks dope spider-man looks
pretty cool I actually thought that was
disappointing really very quick time of
anything that's true obviously wasn't
that impressed I imagine there won't be
a lot of that in the game do I think
that was more just for like spectacle
I was pretty over it they got to show
more to impress me I'm still hopeful but
yeah I was not actually very impressed
with that game PES lawbreakers feel
compared to titanfall two movements be
wise little less precise I'd say this
feel more floaty because it's zero
gravity as far as the fun right yeah but
like you know also true yeah I would say
there's a sense of speed though like
there's definitely in both games have a
good wave just you can build momentum
and just keep it going up with certain
characters that I find really really
satisfying yeah that's like the wraith
because if you'd like to start moving
and then you could jump and then I like
the assassin for the same reason you can
combine like the grapple hook and then
and watch yourself and hop on something
and you can just kind of keep that going
oh
[Music]
which they release the good Tarak game
that'd be pretty cool a good to our game
yeah
has there ever been one so yeah see I'm
gonna shoot myself oh yeah I see what I
was trying to do there we're just
launched myself forward oh it's because
the the clock expired that's why those
like how did I get yeah any changes
depending on the situation now I need
help yeah I mean I don't know I think
this is gonna be a really good
spider-man game though which I think
will be cool which I don't know I'm sure
people in the chat played spider-man 2
hopefully because that game was a really
good spider-man game it's lawbreaker
it's the kind of game that makes you say
one more game cuz I'm debating to get it
I've been feeling pretty good that way
about it for sure it depends on you the
game's gonna be open beta
starting tomorrow so I would say try it
out and this this version I don't know
it feels pretty feature reach for a beta
for a beta as far as like Matt rich yeah
feature-rich yeah future reach future
reach the halo
so as far as playing the game of getting
a good sense of the final game to enjoy
yeah check this out yeah it seems like
every class available except for one
they've got a decent amount of maps riot
you know blue film yeah I'm sure
there'll be a couple more and then
there's a whole story mode no I'm just
kidding there's no yeah Bob Jones just
don't know about the new spider-man felt
like Batman need to see more of it I do
Groot that I think I would like to see
more front of it what I saw I was like
alright this looks really cool I think
Sony announced it too early but I
shouldn't have announced it last year
and I agree with that
I felt like they're they're trying to
fill the pipe last year oh you hit him
too and now that's an ability that I
don't know that when ia yeah a little
too difficult maybe to you Richard
Westerberg this titanfall is a superior
example on how to make a good FPS
shooter the sad part is that it got no
recognition for this game
no no titanfall in fall - he's saying
titanfall spirited this though no no
he's just saying in general Oh in
general yeah I mean I I agree that it's
an underrated game sure that was one one
conversation that we had during our life
picking our e3 games I think he gave
titanfall 3 right well last year last
year yeah I don't remember entirely but
I think like I remember yeah we didn't
let it factor into whether or not where
this game should be on the list but one
thing that was like kind of
disappointing was that it was one of our
favorite games but not too many people
later oh yeah
there we go you guys are gonna make me
get titanfall to it all this talk of
titanfall 2 lol it Rob gave a pretty
impassioned speech yeah it's really good
like if you're yeah it's really good it
is really good and they've been
consistently patching in titanfall 1
into that game like all the maps and
stuff with yeah because not a lot of
people played that one either totally
xbox pc this ball nice don't know how
that happen but this is a close game so
far yeah what are you doing yeah there's
been a good one
drop it oh boy get on that on there
the one thing I hate about tf2 is that
they call it tf2 I know who make a
petticoat team fortress I will never not
think of Team Fortress I know stay with
me I just like t2 but then you can go
Terminator 2 I just say titanfall I feel
like it's a short enough game that it
doesn't mean to it happen over them like
I get like Team Fortress 2 and you say
tf2 like titanfall my time to fall short
enough it's fine I don't need to call
lawbreakers lb mystery chases are you
guys excited for the Last of Us - yes
I'm very excited I am trying to like a
media blackout sort of thing after I saw
the trailer yes right all right I don't
want to see anything else for this fight
I don't think Vince anything else get
they have not showed anything else but I
don't know if that's even possible in
this like yeah and then usually talking
about Red Dead Redemption
- Rockstar doesn't do III - might be
eight games come in August I doubt it
Rockstar probably reveal more when they
feel like it cuz they are what they're
called rockstars kind of just do what
they want Bionic gaming says have you
tried lb on the ps4 yeah left bumper I
played on ps4 any differences yeah you
can speak to that I played a little bit
on both for the most part it's the same
just a little bit slow but it felt good
on gamepad and controller I didn't I
mean now see keyboard is probably the
preferred way to play this game but if
you don't have a PC it's still worth I
mean it's still fun on ps4 agree can't
call titanfall 2 TF - yeah - and the
stream says wow you guys really dropped
the ball there
that way for the shield yeah it's kind
of sitting there no you got him come on
oh no no I kicked him though how long
does the open beta last last till Monday
the third
yeah the thirds yes third is Monday yes
fourth is Tuesday CD Projekt Reds next
game excited to get more about that yeah
every day I wake up and hope that
there's more info on cyber Pearl right
Oh guys guys
oh we're doing so well I have a feeling
when we see cyber Punk again it'll be
III 2018 that would be like next year I
think I think that's Mike that's my
guess
I think the ball oh my god I think
they're gonna show it off for the Xbox
one X they're gonna show how it looks on
the Xbox one x cuz I feel like that game
would be perfectly strong with that and
since they kind of had that little
partnership with Xbox for Witcher 3
mm-hmm I couldn't see that happening
yeah John Luke is very frustrated I'm my
team is mighty has been useless dropping
the ball yeah ones debate out on ps4 I
haven't announced one yet there's
supposed to be one but I'm not sure
William Ramla says what game wasn't it
e3 that you want to see kind of touched
on this a little bit but is there
anything we may have missed up in Red
Dead or cyberpunk
or the past Rose
[Music]
defeat no haven't can't can't think of
anything at the moment other than like
what we've said like last a while so I
asked we saw spider-man homecoming and
if so is it any good we haven't a couple
even the office did and they're gonna
get a review up sounds like in the next
couple days apparently it's really good
yeah what they were saying in the
morning meeting well I think that's
gonna do it for lawbreakers did I got a
couple okay matches not that one right
an s-rank yeah I was pretty good that
was pretty cool
yeah um still not as good as yesterday
yesterday if they were kicking butt but
I think was still it was fresh and it
was fresh fresh meat
yeah breakers they're open beta starts
tomorrow on PC so if you want to check
this out for yourself I mean I think you
should if you have any interest in this
game it's a pretty good beta that gives
you a really good idea of the game
that's gonna go until Monday I've met um
we got a couple more things throughout
the week we got some so I settled a
lobster tomorrow with Peter Rob
definitely check that out that should be
awesome and we're probably gonna all day
it'll probably all day zelda tomorrow
for us probably lots of zelda reboot
goes up sunday this should be this is a
full episode this is kicking off season
2 and it should be a pretty good episode
mhm
I'm excited for that one and you got
some more indie stuff yeah more indie
stuff 8:00 a.m. every day until Saturday
there's already been a couple videos up
so far but basically just highlighting
indie games that you may have missed
during e3 which is definitely worth
checking out so those games are really
cool alright
I think they'll about do it mr. J says
we're good streamers I love you thank
you thank you thank you mr. J appreciate
that especially after some of the hate
we got earlier the chat alright and yeah
see you guys next time bye guys thank
you for watching